i was making a million dollars a year we
had about a third of the
employees at the company making about 35
per year in order to raise that third to
000 i had to lower my pay to 70 000.
that story goes viral 500 million
interactions on social media with nbc's
video becoming the most
shared in network's history the new kind
of people that style themselves as
capitalists they don't believe in
competition
they believe in using their money and
their superior positions of power
to stamp out competition either you're a
zero
which means a non-billionaire you don't
matter
or you're a one which means you're a
billionaire you do matter
that's not what i took from the book
when he said zero to one that's an exact
quote
so you're reading skills how do your
employees trust you 100
what we do is helping small businesses
even if i do
turn out to you know go to the dark side
this you say someday
like we'll all be protected i think
taxation is forced i don't think it's
choice
we have been pushing millions of people
into poverty
with our system is set up to reward and
not
tax the people at the very top and
instead
tax the people at the bottom
[Music]
my guest today did something a couple
years ago that sends shockwaves through
the debate for capitalism
socialism minimum wage are we paying too
much to people are we paying too little
here's what he did you may remember the
story i guarantee you
high odds are against you not having
seen his story dan price is an
entrepreneur
running a successful business he was
making at the time 1.1 million dollar
your income
one of his employees that was making 35
000 all of your income gets pissed off
at him
says you are making too much money
you're not doing it's not fair look
what's going on i can't even have a
regular life
he can't sleep for three days comes back
says you know what
i'm gonna pay everybody seventy thousand
dollars including myself that story goes
viral into tsunamic 500 million
interactions on social media with nbc's
video becoming the most
shared in network's history aside from
that
most read new york times article of the
week front page of reddit for two days
front page of msm
msnbc abc mashable trending article on
upworthy buzzfeed twitter for two days
facebook
i can go on and on he eventually got an
offer to uh uh
go have his own reality tv show with
mark burnett who's the same guy that did
apprentice with president trump
to be the new donald trump on a show
called billion
dollar startup with that being said my
guest today dan price dan thank you so
much for being a guest on valuetainment
for having me so i i got to tell you i
actually
uh uh love the fact that you did this
and let me explain to you why from the
selfish reason i'll tell you why from
the selfish reason
i'm all about case studies you know when
you go to business school i didn't go to
business school but i took a three weeks
something that harvard was doing
and i went there we read through 100
different case studies
and it was great seeing here's what
sephora did here's what you know
ulta did here's what these guys here's
what that guy did and
it takes typically a few months if not a
few years to find out if that
mark you know if that case study worked
or not and for you you kind of taught us
you know you we're kind of watching to
see how you did whether it's the
politicians the business folks
free enterprise or public now that this
has gone by a few years
and there's both a lot of good and a lot
of controversy behind it and it's all
public people can read about it
how do you feel about that decision that
you made a few years ago
yeah i feel good about it for from our
standpoint at gravity payments
i feel like it's made our company a lot
stronger um
i'm grateful for it personally it's made
my life better as well
but i would say on our company it's just
made us
stronger and i'll give you some some
proof points on that so
we had prior to the 70 000 living wage
announcement we had between zero and two
babies born per year
amongst the entire team and we've had
over
60 in less than six years since the
announcement so we had a 10x baby boom
we also had a 10x boom in terms of
people buying homes for the first time
and i feel like that's so critical in
some situations especially in a place
like seattle
where the housing market just goes up
and up and up to get that you know
get that locked in in terms of having a
home that you can control so your rent's
not going to be going up
endlessly that was huge for us we also
had
70 of the people at the company
announced that they had paid down debt
because a lot of people felt like oh
with higher incomes you can get more
debt and you can get yourself
in a way more trapped and our team did
exactly the opposite of that
and uh lastly we between doubled and
tripled our savings rate that people
were using with the company 401k program
so people are saving a lot more for
retirement
so i feel like it's been it's been
really successful for us and it's been
great to be a part of and do you mind
unpacking i mean i just gave like a a
brief intro so the audience kind of
probably said oh i remember that story
maybe yeah i didn't give all the details
of the numbers you know
walk us through how the math works walk
us through
when the decision was made just kind of
give us the details of it if you don't
mind
yeah yeah great point great point so
so we had about a third of the employees
at the company making about 35
000 per year and
um in order to raise that third to 70
000 plus um you know a few others that
were working at the company that were
also under
70 000 per year it was going to cost us
about two million dollars which was a
hundred percent of our profitability at
that time
and um you know it was one of these
things where
it just seemed like like a moral
imperative
especially because at that time i was
making a million dollars a year so i
took a million dollar paycheck
can i stop you just for example i'm
curious so a third of your employees
were making thirty five thousand dollars
uh thirty five thousand dollars per year
did you say another third was making
less or they were making
uh what was they were they were making
so i don't know if it was quite a third
but there was probably there was a third
that was making more than seventy
thousand a year and maybe like close to
a third in the middle
yeah so a third was making 35 a third
was making
above 70 000. what percentage was making
say
above 100 000 above 200 000 at the time
oh um you know just a handful of us
you know um definitely there were there
were there were a handful maybe a dozen
at the most but not
not more than that okay so that was the
thing i'll bring you back to where it
was before i interrupted you
because i want the audience to hear the
whole part of it he said at the time in
order for us to bring the dirt to from
35 000 to
70 000 we would have to use our two
million dollars of profits that we had
it would have been 100 of it
and you were making 1.1 million continue
from there before i interrupted you
please go ahead
yeah yeah okay sounds good so um
so yeah we we have the third making uh
35 000 here that they were really due to
get their pay doubled
and at the time we had two about 2
million in profits plus i was making a
million dollars per year
so it was going to cost us over 2
million
a year to make the change so i had to
lower my pay
to 70 000 so we'd have that savings plus
put
most of the company's profits at risk to
basically
pay for the change but what that meant
was a third of the people
working at the company were not only
getting their pay doubled but they were
getting paid an amount that was
in line with what scientific studies
including uh by princeton a 2010
princeton study said
if you make less than this amount it's
really harming your well-being
and so it was important for us as a
company to take our responsibility
seriously to not have a pay policy
to harm people's well-being and so
that's why it was i call it a moral
imperative
meaning it was not something that i felt
like we should do it was something i
felt like we absolutely had to do
um had to do how to do had to do and so
we came out we made the announcement and
as you said there was a lot of initial
positive attention but there was also
quite a bit of controversy
and there were seven or eight big you
know
in our world felt big story lines about
the controversy about it
but the biggest one by far was that
conservative talk radio host
rush limbaugh had come out and said that
we were going to fail and he said we
would be a case study
in mba programs about how
socialism does not work because the
entire company was going to go out of
business
and he was predicting this and then when
rush limbaugh set out that big firestorm
the new york times did a story largely
on the fact that rush limbaugh
was trying to tank us and uh centered
around
all of the challenges that we were
facing with such a huge backlash in fact
the headline in the new york times
that was as you said the the top read
story of the week
was uh was a back was about a backlash
the whole headline was about the
backlash and then rush limbaugh
came out with that and put on his
website
what rush was right and he said that we
were going out of business
and he had my picture all of his website
saying we were
we were going under and so
um fortunately though it did become a
case study at harvard
um that they are teaching right now in
fact i heard from a harvard
professor an endowed harvard professor
just in the last week
that he's still teaching the case study
and uh
and it's been successful it's a case
study showing how this sort of thing
works and when you pay people more your
company is going to be more successful
i'd love to see that case study but i
think it's also a little too early
to get all of it i think it'll take a
decade or two to get it but again
i am in a selfish way thankful you did
it
i'm i'm thankful and selfish for you
because we're all learning right now
believe it or not everybody's learning
one person is taking this
and everybody else gets to kind of watch
and see how this works now i got two
questions for you
one is more business-wise the other one
is philosophical so let's stay on the
business side first and then we'll go
philosophical
on the business end
your top-line revenue at the time versus
your top line revenue today i mean
obviously you've helped people have more
sex because you're saying it's 10x how
many babies people are having so
your employees are definitely happy when
they go home they're making babies so
kudos to you
you're helping increase the population
but top line revenue from the moment you
made the decision to today how much has
it grown
uh it's triple okay so three and when
was it when you announced it what's the
exact date
2015. 2015. so in six years
uh your top line has tripled which
respect to that
your profit yeah and just just to
clarify too in our industry how we
measure the most important metric that
people look at in our industry because
there are a few different ways of
looking at it is
merchant processing volume process so
all the 20 000 small businesses that use
gravity
for their payment processing are
processing
triple the amount of small business
payments acceptance through gravity
system
as they were in 2015. well the one thing
to give you credit
this is not a business you did to make
money this was a cause driven business
because you were not happy about what
visa and mastercard were doing to
you know the amount of fees they were
charging with them yeah you wanted to
come i said as much as you guys are
paying taxes
what visa mastercard is doing is nothing
close to what
taxes are doing so i i want to make sure
the audience knows that you did this for
the right reason
but your top line revenue has 3x in six
years
how are you managing your profit margin
as an entrepreneur running your business
how do you manage that
so we get together the whole company
which we just did
since it was you know um like the start
of a new year not too long ago
yeah we get together as a whole team and
we decide
how we're going to determine that you
know for the next
few years because we kind of do it
somewhat on a rolling basis
and out of the 200 there's about 55
people that either volunteer or are
nominated by their peers
to basically make those decisions and
then we get together
for an entire week uh this year we did
it virtually on zoom
but we get together for an entire week
and we have
really long meetings and we go through
and we try to figure out
how much profit margin do we need to be
safe as a company and how much can we
invest and you know increase budgets and
those sorts of things so we figure it
out
all together have you come up with a
sweet spot is it five percent ebitda is
it ten percent ebitda do you have a
number for it
um you know sometimes we do
it it really it depends so much on
circumstances
but i would say you know um one of the
things that we think about is managing
for longevity
because we don't we don't want to lay
anybody off
which we never have and we also want to
be there for small businesses when times
are tough we want to be strong when
times are tough
and so that that is normally what causes
us to say oh you know we we need to be
making some profit so that we can you
know stay strong and and build up our
savings
and say 10 what number would you say 5
10 20 well
it depends on which number you're
talking about because our
our business is kind of convoluted and
it it it might take a little bit to kind
of get into it but basically
just to kind of give you like our
numbers like
we what we process in payments
you know is like roughly like 15 billion
dollars a year
in round numbers and then from that
what our small businesses pay to us to
process those payments
is roughly a little bit less than 300
million dollars
and then most of that is
interchange that goes to visa and
mastercard and that's the money
that the card that issued the the the
the bank that issued that bank card they
get that money
and so that takes us down to about like
45 million
something like that and then from that
you know we try to eke out like a profit
of you know four or five million dollars
to basically
yeah yeah like pay so so it's it's ten
percent of the net number
or the another way to think of it as
like two percent of the gross number
just so you know i fully know your
business model you're an iso right
you're an iso yeah you're
i had a merchant account company years
ago i'm very familiar with the model how
it works
uh uh and uh uh so okay so on the top
line
uh let's just say 45 million you're
netting 4 million so that's about 10
what do you guys do with that for do you
just sit on it do you wait for other
projects
does it kind of make the company
stronger so if we want to bring more
people on how do you guys use that four
million
yeah basically all of those ways um we
we did have a a company approach us in
boise
and they were called charge it pro and
they said well
if we sell this company charge it pro
to anybody else in your industry or to
any investors
they're going to lay off our employees
and consolidate a lot of that work into
a larger
company and all those employees in idaho
at the time they had 40 employees
those employees are going to get laid
off and they're going to lose their job
and so the owners of that company came
to us and said hey
you know we really feel like you would
be the right ones to like
take this on because we know that you
all are in it for the long haul and we
know you believe in taking care of
employees so
we can trust you and you're literally
the only buyer
so you know i don't know like what i
have to keep private for them or whatnot
but it was a
still a substantial amount of money that
we needed to pay to like make all that
happen
and integrate the two companies and then
secondarily
that company their median wage was 25
000 a year
and so we had to triple the pay
[Laughter]
of over half the employees yeah
after the acquisition and whereas like
our competitors would be thinking about
laying off all those employees
we we literally were working on tripling
all like half of the employ more than
half of the employees pay
but that was like an example where we
took on some debt
to the seller and so a lot of that
profit for a number of years after that
went to pay down that like debt to that
seller
so that's an example and um and then
another example would be
would be savings and and taxes got it
okay that makes sense uh so
so going back to uh the question with a
business let's stay on business still
uh currently right now your org chart if
we were to look at your org chart on
what it was
in 2015 when you announced this versus
what it is today i asked you
how many people did you have making over
100 000 or 200 000
you said maybe a handful you were making
1.1 did you have anybody as a second uh
highest over 200 how many did you have
over six figures
and what happened to those uh uh c-suite
executives that you had
yeah so um i believe
all of them uh
stayed for at least quite a while and i
think the majority are still there
i mean i'd have to kind of like think
through like how many employees you got
by the way how many total employees do
you have
a little under 200 we're we're we're
doing
a hiring push right now that'll get us
over 200.
when you say you have to check to see if
they're with you did you have any
c-suite executives then or you didn't
not really i mean well okay yes and no
so
it's hard to say because a lot of the
people that are in
kind of top leadership positions at
gravity they've been there their whole
career they started their career at
gravity
and so we all kind of work more like as
a team and we've had to
like get more clarity on things like org
chart and everything mostly just for for
people
from the outside coming in so they can
be more comfortable
and feel more of a sense of transparency
that they understand who to talk to and
what's going on
but that was very unnatural for us
because
you know i started building this company
when i was 17.
i i came from rural idaho i grew up
literally down the street from a dump
and so i didn't
i knew some of those things but i just
like the feeling of basically helping
small businesses
and i really enjoyed that so i did that
like 17 18 and 19 then i launched
officially gravity at 19 and then it was
more
just like finding people that liked that
just as much as i did
and so we were kind of all doing it
together so a lot of those
folks you know are still at the company
and
some are in leadership positions some
have been in leadership positions but
then
found that they actually preferred being
in a role where they just can help
customers directly because that's what
originally attracted them to the company
so we have people that have been
executives at the company that are still
at the company that are not executives
today and are much happier not you know
being in a position that
suits what they like to do better so
that's why it's like a little bit hard
to answer like with precision
but i will say that um it also tends
to be a bit of a rotating role sometimes
and i don't know why this
is but we do have a a lot of people at
the company who are first-time
managers first-time leaders and
and and then we have a lot of people at
the company who have been in those
management leadership positions but
found it was not really
anything that they enjoyed too much but
they wanted to stay at the company
as an individual contributor so it's a
bit of a
a it's a bit of a spaghetti salad for
you
yeah you know you just took me to a
whole different place when i'm thinking
about your
your business model is how do you sell
the vision
like when you say hey you know one day
we're going to be
what one day hey johnny i want you to
work on yourself in these areas because
one day
you're going to be able to
what is that well one day i'm gonna be
what sell me the vision how do you sell
me the vision when i'm in the meeting
with you or is it
the complete opposite where you say who
cares about a nice car who cares about a
nice house who cares about having a
million and a bank
who cares about being rich who cares
about going to hawaii who cares about
going to europe who cares
how do you sell the vision of where the
individual is going and where the
company is going
yeah yeah i i i i hear what you're
saying
and the way i would think of it is like
do you
tell somebody that they should want lots
of money
or do you tell somebody that they should
not want lots of money
and my answer is i don't tell people
what they want they decide what they
want
and so i don't really i don't it's up to
them
i know in general what the social
science says
about human beings which is the way
people are motivated
at the highest level and the way the the
people that make the most important
achievements
get find their motivation is through
internal drive they call in intrinsic
motivation as opposed to extrinsic but
basically
autonomy mastery purpose and social
connection
are the four strongest motivators on
earth but
something like money or title or
prestige
is a much more common motivator because
if you're motivated by money or title or
prestige or power
then you tend to get those things and
you tend to use those things to control
other people and also just human nature
money prestige power those more
competitive type
motivations they are they're very
enticing to people they're alluring to
people but they're not as strong
in terms of actually causing people to
do good work they're short-term positive
motivators but in the long term
they tend to make people in general not
every person there's certainly
exceptions but in general
they tend to make people kind of
miserable and unmotivated
and so what we do is instead try to
create a platform together
whereby all of us myself included
can do things that make us feel alive
can do things that make us feel meaning
and for us what brings us together
originally
was helping small businesses but
secondarily
what when we said well why why do we
love helping small businesses so much
is because we like the little guy we
want to help the little guy
and that's what motivates us and so can
i do what though help the little
guy do what because i'm a little guy i
started off as a little guy so this is a
guy
i like blood i grew up in a divorce
family i lived at a refugee camp in
germany 10 years iran so i was a 1.8 gpa
kid i went to the army i was a welfare
kid
i don't have a four-year degree i don't
have a two-year degree i didn't have
anything i'm i'm the guy that had a
lunch ticket going to school from
seventh grade till
12th grade and i've never taken english
101 it's always been esl my entire life
i've only taken esl
so define what is helping the little guy
what is helping the little guy mean to
you
well so the way we got there was
you know these small businesses were
obviously being
bullied by the system overall
by visa and mastercard they set the
rates that the small businesses pay
and like twice a year they raise the
rates
on the small businesses and there's no
competition
it's not like the business can be like
okay i'm gonna stop taking visa i'm not
i'm gonna stop taking mastercard
and so the small businesses basically
have to
take whatever these big huge companies
say that they have to take
and it's really wrong and you know in a
place like idaho where i grew up
you know you see the impact of that on
those small businesses far away from
that board room in new york city
where they decided we can increase our
share price
by charging these small businesses that
can't afford it a bunch of fees
for money that we don't need to run our
business that we're then going to use
to inflate our stock with stock buybacks
so that we can pay executive bonuses
and so i was seeing that as a 17 year
old
and there was a coffee shop named moxie
java caldwell in caldwell idaho and
there was
the owner heather hempel she was
explaining to me
how she was getting screwed over and she
didn't necessarily know all the
backstory of like how it all works
behind that but she was explaining me
she was getting screwed over
and she introduced me to some of her
friends that said the same thing so it's
like
how do we fight against this how do we
hold these big companies accountable
but the name of the game right now in
business and in big tech and big
companies in big wall street
is captured in the work of peter thiel
the book zero to one where he wrote
competitionists for losers
so what the new kind of people that
style themselves as capitalists actually
believe
they don't believe in competition they
believe in using
their money and their superior positions
of power
to stamp out competition and
the entire economy is starting to line
up with that philosophy
and you see it in the book zero to one
you thought that yeah
i was saying in the book that's not what
i took from the book when he said zero
to one
well he he's he that says an exact quote
so your reading skills may be
where you know that i know that but i
think what he was trying to say is have
you read blue ocean strategy
yeah yeah i think that's the direction
where he was going
like create a market where there is no
competition like you know where you're
where you're going into a place where
you're the you know first one to go out
there and do it you don't have anybody
else to compete against versus go
destroy everybody and
dominate the entire market well well
that's what theo was talking about
let's look at the weight of the evidence
to see if
what your your your posit is correct or
mine
so he made two other big points the two
biggest points in the book actually that
contextualized the statement
number one if you really want to be
significant if you really want to matter
you need to be a billionaire
that was his first point in the book and
that's very much
in line with zero to one it's binary
what he means by that do you know what
he means let me let
let me finish and then and then i'll and
then i'll see what
yeah i do know what he means i think i
do tell me
yeah yeah either you're a zero
which means a non-billionaire
you don't matter
or you're a one which means you're a
billionaire you do matter
that's the ideology that regular people
all over are seeing
and it's one thing for us to say well i
want to
keep that intact because i want to get
there i want to climb that ladder
but if you look at the social mobility
statistics that are out there right now
having a ladder like that isn't
climbable and here's why it's his second
point so that's his first thesis point
but he has two parallel theses in that
book how do you become a billionaire
how do you become somebody that matters
he asks that question
and he says that the only way to become
a billionaire
is to have a monopoly and the reason why
is because if you have a monopoly you
can act with impunity
there's no accountability and he uses
softer language
than that but if you think about the
implication you can
lay off employees with no consequences
you can go be like uber eats and you can
get cardi b and dana carvey to do some
kind of
wayne's world commercial and spend 10
million dollars
at the same time that your business
model
is trying to extract maximum value
from local businesses and you do a
commercial claiming that you're helping
local businesses
at the same time you're laying off
employees at the same time you're paying
huge executive bonuses
and at the same time that you're buying
out competitors
i mean this is what people on reddit
that some people would call or crazy
think of as late stage capitalism
because it's like where can you actually
take things
after this like where do you go next and
basically
since the 1970s or the 1980s
so much of our success in business has
been about
squeezing people about exploiting
workers that's been the that's been
around the economy
but now it's becoming just more and more
scammy throughout and if you think about
your own life
just when you go out and live your life
how many scams are you subjected to on a
daily weekly or monthly basis now or how
many times
are you kind of slightly mistreated and
it could be little things like getting
the text to lose a hundred pounds with a
diet pill i'm looking at you you
definitely should not lose 100 pounds
that would be a bad thing
it could be the the scam phone call
claiming to be
social security administration it could
be
it could be the fact that you know you
used to check into a hotel
and whatever price they told you the
price was was the actual price and now
there's a 50
resort fee or you go into an airline
and you can pay yeah the rate that they
advertise but to do it you're going to
sit in the middle seat by the bathroom
and so so much more of our economy now
is designed to extract maximum resources
engineer use those resources to marshal
to marshall you know engineering
capabilities
and then engineering a space away from
competition
or away from actual even customers i
mean
we have examples of businesses like uber
eats
that will claim that they're advertising
for a local company and then be
redirecting
that company's customers to a different
company and it's a complete scam and
it's legal and so going back to peter
thiel
with his second point of how do you
become a billionaire
he said the only way to do it really is
to become
a monopoly so that you can act with
impunity so
what i'm sharing to you about heather
and other people like you
that didn't start out from much they're
being held down
more than you realize by this system
that we're all supporting
and yeah it's true that we have
individual examples
like yourself that show the way and show
wow somebody can be successful
but what those examples do and i'll i'll
actually point the finger at myself
more than anybody else but what those
examples do
is they kind of lie to us they make us
think
that the system does promote and allow
people to get ahead
when actually the fact that that we get
held up you and i get held up on
pedestals proves the opposite it proves
that we
are the exception and it proves that
most people don't reach that
and just for myself you know you pointed
out how
500 million people had seen my story
and how people were so enthusiastic
about it how low
is the bar when somebody who basically
says the people actually creating the
value
should get it they should have autonomy
and we should work together to help
small businesses
gets that kind of attention how much
does that prove
how low the bar is because everything
that i did you can't find a single thing
i did
that a nice eight-year-old wouldn't do
let me know and yet that was the
response yeah so i think it shows
everything about where we are right now
no i think i think the reason why that
story went viral is because the younger
generation reloads
relates to a ton and they're coming out
of college and they're more in the state
of
rich people are bad people capitalism
sucks because that's what the university
is doing that's what they're teaching
them
and then all of a sudden they see a
story like you and they're gonna share
the hell out of it and i'm glad
it got the exposure because we need to
have this discussion here's my question
for you
your company is doing four million a
year
okay net four four and a half million
years what the number is let's just say
four and a half million a year ten
percent is the number
let's say that just so you know ten
percent is relatively what the average
merchant account company does
it's about it it's a very small margin
merchant account is not big margins
you don't make a lot of profit on
merchant accounts there are some that
abuse it back in the days and the 90s
where they would sell the equipment for
financing if you remember for 199
well you weren't around at that time but
they would sell it for 199
36 month period and people were making
money but nowadays machines are
generally free
it's more on the fees that people play
around okay so
you're making the same amount of profits
that the average merchant account
company is making
are you the 100 owner of the company or
is the company shared with everybody the
equity
i own the company okay so so if you own
100 the company that means you're
probably worth
100 to 200 million dollars because in
in the world of merchant account the x
is higher you know it's a 20 to 40 x
type of a number you and i know this
would you would you feel confident or
comfortable
giving your 200 employees a half a
percent of your company to make it fair
that everybody owns a piece
yeah i think that's a good idea so we've
we've had a lot of internal discussions
about that over the years
and i'm open to it um the the reason why
it hasn't happened so far
is there's a there's a belief amongst
the team
that if you kind of buy into the
shareholder supremacy model that you're
kind of pitching me right now
and the idea that shareholders um should
maximize like what they get
which is kind of what your question is
predicated on
if we have shareholders then we will
have to behave
in that way as the concern and i think
that there is a legal defense
and a legal basis to say that no that's
not the case
but it could be tricky especially if
somebody is in a situation where
if we started acting in accordance with
these
principles that you and i disagree on
about peter thiel where i don't want to
do that i don't believe in
screwing people over i don't believe in
screwing over those small businesses you
didn't say screw people over peter thiel
never said screwing people oh well
peter thiel said a monopoly and to have
a monopoly you and i both know in order
to have a monopoly you need the
government to do monopoly he never said
screw people over to be a billionaire
that's not his words but i do know what
you're saying you said number one
is to matter is to be a billionaire and
then
you know the other part when you said is
to have a monopoly yeah he did say that
and i recall on the books i've read it
multiple times
yeah well and that informs what he meant
when he said competition is for losers
because in his mind loser and
non-billionaire
are basically the same they're very
close
no you you just said right now to screw
people over like peter thiel said i want
to make sure i
differentiate those two because i don't
remember him saying make your money by
screwing people over that's just your
belief
system that you think screwing people
over
well i don't think it's that much of a
leap
okay so let me go back to the question i
asked the question i asked you you
thought i was asking it from the
standpoint of
maximizing the shareholder profits
that's not what happened yeah so the way
the way we the way we run the company
the the
it's not worth that much no no that's
not what i was asking about my question
was more or less
about if you if you feel everyone's
making 70k and you're making 70k
why not share the equity company with
everybody why own 100 of it because
you're sitting there worth a couple
hundred million
why not have them have a few hundred
thousand dollars of net worth added to
them
yeah so it's because the
the the the shares currently
like we're not public like so the shares
aren't
you can't like go sell them you know
what i mean oh but
you can give a uh a stock options where
the individual can invest over a five
year period
and there are a lot of people that work
for companies who are not public that
give shares
that allows the individual to build up
their network because right now your
employees don't have a high net worth
you do
so although you are being very noble on
the area of giving everybody a 70 000
salary i'm thinking if you're gonna go
that why not go fully and give everybody
a piece of the company so it's equally
shared with everyone
expect because if you do that then that
takes the case study again remember i'm
coming from a selfish place because i
want to see how this thing works long
term
on the case study so if you did 200
employees
get a half a percent and you put a
five-year vessel period that they have
to stay there
would you consider doing that yeah
absolutely i think it's a great idea but
i'll say
i'm not sure that i'm really able to
to connect with you or explain to you
like like what
some of the danger and downside would be
to doing it but i still think
it it's a it's it's something good that
we need to consider either way
yeah but i think but i think that it's
so hard
i think i could be wrong but i think
it's so hard
because we're so deep in the system
the economic system it's so hard i think
for somebody that's like working at that
deep level in the system
to understand a world divorced from
shareholder supremacy
and i think that i think that if you
could understand
like a a world other
than shareholder supremacy i think it
would
make the way that you're thinking
through and analyzing an issue very
different
yeah the only way i'm thinking about it
is i'm thinking about it in a way of
uh hey this is the amount of money that
came in why don't we take the money that
came to
la district county and let's get the
money to do so if you have equity
you because you you're you're in a very
you're very well let me try to explain
it to you i
i feel like i feel like you're i feel
like you really want to understand so
let me try really hard to explain it to
you
i don't think i want to understand let
me explain to my question i think you
got to understand my question here's my
question
my question isn't like i run a comment
we don't think that way right so you're
saying how come you guys don't think the
way i think
no and i'm like i don't think the way
you think i don't exactly
what you think yeah so i don't know how
to answer the question then
what i'm saying to you is if you're
worth 200 million why don't you give
equal amount of shares to your employees
so they also i'm not worth 200 million
say 100 million whatever i'm not worth
100 million
i asked you earlier if you're doing four
and a half million ebitda they pay you
20 to 40 percent that's about 100
million dollar network
no it no it isn't how is it not ok
if a person wanted to buy if i if i were
to right now you're a pretty transparent
guy that's what made you unique what
made you unique is the fact that you
were willing to be transparent you were
very much about
my income's 1.1 yeah yeah i mean i would
love to explain it to you i don't know
if i'm going to be able to but i'll try
if you want
i'm all ears tell us okay so
currently the way the economy works
as i understand it is
the the most important thing that drives
the companies
is this thing that this guy milton
friedman came up with right
shareholder value and basically the
companies
are currently run in general
with what's going to enhance the stock
price
at some time horizon and then the
the there's something that the
compensation
experts do called alignment
incentive alignment and basically what
they do is they take those stock price
targets
and things that the corporation wants to
achieve like a higher stock price and
they set up
incentives for the executives and
employees and stuff like that
so that it creates what the what the
experts call
alignment between the shareholders
who are kind of set up as the pr
primary beneficiary of the of the scheme
and it creates a harmonious it purports
to create a harmonious relationship
between them
and quote unquote management or top
executives
so that they'll be aligned so that the
when they have to make a really tough
decision
that's going to prop up the stock price
that incentive is designed to make sure
that the executives make the decision
that's good for the shareholders good
for the stock price
and the value the multiples that you
talked about
are predicated on having a management
team
that and and a setup of a company
that's run in this matter if you
took the exact same metrics
but you told shareholders they can never
lay off employees ever
if you took the exact same metrics and
you told employees
you can never raise customer prices
in a way that's an unjustifiable money
grab
if you told the investors they were no
longer allowed to do those things
and they wouldn't be able to expect any
type of liquidity event from the company
really ever but not on any specific time
horizon and they couldn't create it
then the value of those shares would be
depressed
significantly and it would basically
create a situation where it was
a fraction the company would be worth in
that scenario a fraction of what it's
otherwise worth so
in a world in a world where we're
planning
to join this kind of scam
that everybody can see that i think you
may
you know you may be bought into a little
bit
if we if we decide that we're willing to
participate in that scam and
just to just to have the rubber meet the
road for you because i think this one
will really land with you
i had a gentleman come up to me who
i've known for for close to two decades
been a mentor of mine been a ceo of
multiple successful companies in our
industry
and run multi multiple multi-billion
dollar companies in our industry and he
came up to me and said dan
i could come join gravity or somebody
like me
and i could turn this into a
multi-billion dollar company
within a few years because if we
unwound this and that you know like
not doing layoffs in the pandemic when
our competitor toast
used it as an excuse to laugh 50 of
their employees
when their value is going from five
billion to eight billion dollars
not doing a hundred dollar uh price
increase in the pandemic to small
businesses
like our competitor heartland that's
owned by global payments a public
company
these are the the playbooks and the
models in our industry
and the value that you're putting out
there
is it is based on the idea that you're
going to play ball
in this way and ob was saying that and i
was like you know what
i don't think the world needs another
billionaire and i don't even know that
the world needs like a whole lot more
like
multi-millionaires out there i think
what we need
is a company that's willing to stick up
for what's right
stick stick up for these principles and
the way we run the organization
currently
when we get together and make decisions
is we do it
as if shareholders don't exist so we we
consider shareholders
at zero when we're considering how to
run the company
all of a sudden if we create the type of
incentive alignment
that somebody who's like a hardcore
capitalist like an unapologetic
unapologetic capitalist would yeah would
would
would try to get us to do are we
still going to run the company in the
same way after that
right and the answer to that is maybe
not and i would like to think that we're
all such good people
that we would turn away from the
opportunity to make more money
to stick up for what's right to stick up
for our values but currently
we just do it by basically taking all of
that money
and and basically considering it to be
money that's really
most rightfully you know uh considered
uh
as an asset for clients small businesses
employees how can we use these resources
to help
and all of a sudden if we created that
kind of incentive
alignment structure it would it would
really
take us and make us less of what we are
and more of what companies that you're
used to seeing
i gotta tell you i understand what
you're saying i listen to every word you
said very good explanation i understand
philosophically where you stand
where it's hey pat i don't think my
company is what you think it is because
if i were to sell it which i never will
i would have to go by the new buyers
guidelines of having to sell in the
future which i wouldn't want
which means a person that would buy
today i don't think the margin is going
to be 20 to 40 times which i wouldn't
agree to
but still you're 100 owner and this is
the risk where i see
and i want to kind of tell you this and
and try to destroy my argument
say you're you're you're a fool you have
no clue what the hell you're talking
about destroy do whatever you want to do
with it because i want to i want to kind
of get your perspective
so if i work for you
and i'm one of your 70 000 your
employees at the 200
that's doing 45 million top line revenue
that the company is keeping four and a
half percent four and a half million ten
percent
net profit and which you own a hundred
percent of
i have to almost believe you are
jesus or god or somebody of such power
to trust a hundred percent
that you will never flip i have to
almost trust
you 100 which then you become like a god
figure and that's a lot of pressure
yeah because most people who are human
beings like you and i
i'm not sure if you've tried to walk on
water i've tried many times i fail every
single time maybe you have i can't
so then then i have to sit there and say
why do
i don't trust 100 how do your employees
trust
you 100 percent do they kind of see you
as a god or how how
do they see you like a prophet how do
your employees see you
yeah well a couple things um
because i want to i want to answer your
question very specifically about
us but then i want to make a broader
point about how i think it relates
to your you know you and and other
people out there and
people watching us right now
so i think it just
shows again my main point about how low
the bar
is because we assume
and frankly pretty much correctly so
that everybody out there that has
ownership
and power and those sorts of things is
going to flip
and basically trade the things that
matter in life
which are relationships care
love trust integrity for the things that
don't matter in life
uh or don't matter as much once you have
enough
so money really matters it buys
happiness
but it doesn't buy happiness once you're
making a 100 or 150 or 200 000 a year it
doesn't buy happiness
certainly when you're making three or
four hundred thousand a year if you make
more than that that's not
in general for most people going to help
them
and so we assume that we are all so
greedy and power hungry and that might
be a safe assumption
that might be a safe assumption and that
might be a safe assumption about me but
if it is
then what we need to do is so clear
we need to have a very high tax rate
with wealthy people and we need to
set rules because soon with ai
and robotics and all that being private
we're going to have these
private armies of security we're going
to have these people
that control a level of power
over all of us and when you think about
automation
when you think about the fact that so
many jobs are going to be eliminated
something like ubi universal basic
income
these are the types of uh solutions that
we need to institute and
what i'll say is here's here's my big
failing
here's where i really do think i failed
i've allowed myself to become
an excuse for the current system and
perpetuating the status quo because
people can point at my story
and say hey this guy came from very
humble beginnings grew up in idaho
look at what he did but the reality is
you're exactly right because zero big
companies have followed suit
and as a result we have we have been
pushing
millions of people into poverty with
our system as set up to basically reward
and not tax the people at the very top
the millionaires and billionaires
and instead be predatory scammy and
tax the people at the bottom so if we
all work together
in unison with one voice to reverse that
system
that's really our last line of defe of
of protection
overall and in my company we should
institute
some of those rules so that even if i do
turn out to you know go to the dark side
as you say someday
like we'll all be protected yeah so
a couple things one i agree i think we
do need a flat tax it sounds like you're
pitching a flat tax right now where
everybody gets taxed the same exactly
i'm pitching i'm pitching over 10
million i would be
super comfortable with a 50 60 or even
70 percent maybe even 80 90
tax rate i think we need to get the
where has that worked dan what what
countries has a
70 80 90 tax rate ever worked
the united states for one when we
implemented this
in the in the 40s and 50s we had two
periods in a row that were about a
decade at each where
median incomes doubled after we did it
so it's worked right here in the united
states but
currently it's working very well in
places like
costa rica in denmark in norway
90 over over a huge amount yes
yeah yeah but i think you're not talking
about income you're talking about the
elizabeth warren if you're worth over 50
million
that's a wealth tax you're talking about
i think we need gold
i think we need both let me go back to
this so yeah i think
uh one on them trusting you 100 i think
you ought to consider giving 100 of your
equity to all your employees i think you
ought to consider doing that
and then also writing you down and
saying in the constitution
before i give the shares to you if we
ever sell and anybody who buys the
company has to be agreeing to the
constitution
the profits goes to you but you cannot
philosophically change
the following bylaws so if i'm coming to
buy i may not pay you 40x
but i'll pay 10x and all the employees
that own some of the shares
they'll get profit so i think you ought
to consider giving out your let me but
let me just say
if you end up coming to work at gravity
payments at any point
your opinion on this will will it
already matters and i'll already listen
what you say and think about it but if
you worked at gravity
and you wanted to talk to employees
about this idea
and see like do you have support i'd be
super excited about it
by the way i'd love to come talk to your
employees i'm being that serious with
you
i'd love to but i mean you have to be
working there for a while first
and gain their credibility if you want
me you you don't want me to talk to your
200 employees it wouldn't be good
you don't want no no i wouldn't i
wouldn't mind it's just i have to
yeah no but i think i think that
there's such a disconnect with how you
see the world than how we see the world
that i feel like in order for your
message to really land
i feel like there's a certain amount of
like
i'm dangerous you see for me i like to
talk to guys i don't think you're
dangerous
i see i don't think you are either but
you yeah so the one thing that
i i can say almost everybody that i know
who has strong opinions about the
opposing side
they also make assumptions you've made a
lot of assumptions you yourself even in
this recording if you go back and listen
to it
you've made the assumptions of whether
how wealthy people are how billionaires
are
whether you've said people that make
over three hundred thousand dollars
they're not as happy as i would assume i
said in general
this the science proves that no no no
so an assumption let me let me parse
this out for you so
an assumption would be to say about one
person as an individual
yeah but the scientific studies say
this is true for people in general you
can't pull out one person from that that
would be an assumption
i'm going to call the assumption cops to
come and audit both of us
i want to say to all the assumptions
cops out there to all the assumptions
cops
if i made assumptions comment below give
me the minute if dan made assumptions
hold us accountable put it below i'm
willing to say if i made assumptions
as long as my buddy dan is also willing
to commit to if he made assumptions
and everybody can do that survey and
we'll talk about that you and i
afterwards
so so then question for you i'm i'm very
curious
in the way you were raised how's your
relationship right now with your family
how are you with mom dad
your brother your sister how's the
family relationships
oh i mean i i don't want to get into
that too much just to protect everyone's
privacy but i love my family
so much and i'm so grateful for them the
reason why i say that is because of one
thing that's so interesting about you
you were a bible memorization
competition
in fifth and sixth grade i mean that's
crazy to me dan like
i have a hard time remembering john 3
16. you're talking about
memorizing bibles he was raised as a
conservative christian family
where he and his siblings took turns
walking waking
at 5 a.m to make breakfast before bible
readings you know
and i mean are you still do you still
subscribe to any of the christian
evangelical philosophies or no
i would say my belief about those things
is
um is a constant uh
growth and the way i would the way i
would uh answer specifically is like
there was a actually a christian pastor
that i was talking to one time and i
said paul
and i wrote about this in my book so
it's it's out there
but i said paul like don't you lose
sleep
worrying if maybe this stuff isn't true
and he said no i never lose sleep over
that and i was like why like i'm like so
worried about it
you know what i mean and he was like dan
i just i focus on growing and opening up
my mind and trying to learn
everything i can but our beliefs
evolve so fast and even christianity
means something totally different today
than it did 20 years ago
and so his his philosophy which i i
to you christianity means something
different than 20 years ago or to the
world
i would say to the world there's the
contours have evolved in the last 20
years assumption that could be
categorically an assumption right there
we found one right there dan how is it
an assumption
you're assuming it's different 20 in the
last 20 years what's changed in the last
20 years with christianity i'm curious
well um you're speaking to 25 or eight
years so just just assume
i'm being serious with you yeah the 25
year atheist right
well that might explain why it's coming
across differently than i intend because
you know growing up studying theology
for an hour every day
which i did for a long time
and in particular christian theology
which is where i spent the majority of
my time
the the the kind of what we call the
canon of christianity
like the center of christianity most
christian
scholars believe that it's a combination
of things
including tradition including culture
and the apostle paul who's one of the
most famous
authors in the bible or supposed authors
depending on what you believe there
the apostle paul when he would write
letters to different churches
he would tell one church something that
i think is inexcusable but you know i'll
just use an example he would say like oh
with this follow these sets of rules and
then for another church he'd say follow
these sets rules
and peter came who was you know the high
apostle to
jesus and peter came and he
and paul was leading this church where
he wasn't following all the rules about
what you can eat and what you can eat
and paul was explaining to peter that
he believes that christianity is
it's an interaction between their faith
and the culture and the people of that
day does that make sense
and so he was explaining to peter how
like those things and peter and him had
a fight
and this was going to be a big problem
you have your two most powerful leaders
in your church and they're having uh
like a a knockout
fight and peter had a dream where
there was a big cloth and it tore
and this was the most important cloth in
the world
and there were all these animals that
paul was saying they could
eat that all of a sudden peter had this
sense from his dream that they were okay
now
so that was like a moment like in the
canon of christianity
where like the the the religion
evolves but i mean most
i don't want to say all but the vast
majority of
theologians and the vast majority indeed
of christian theologians specifically it
it they this is just an accepted fact
for them
that the church is constantly kind of
changing because
initially it was like an oral tradition
where things would be passed down
from generation to generation and now
you can have a situation where
you know the bible still holds up
as the most talked about issue
caring for those who don't have enough
making sure people's basic needs are met
that's the top issue in the bible it's
the top sin that's discussed
people not having their basic needs met
and it's the top
positive thing that's discussed in the
bible people having those basic needs
met and equality is
part of that discussion but sometimes
some of the more divisive and political
issues of the day
end up being the one that the church
grapples with more and
and so the church sometimes
has a situation where you know the bible
didn't change so the bible's still
talking about feeding people that are
hungry
but the church may be talking about any
number of issues that are a little bit
more of like the
hot button issues of the day and the and
the things evolve so
the most the largest christian church in
the world is the roman catholic church
and for example they had something
called vatican ii
where they said oh now we're not going
to
do our services in latin anymore we're
going to do them in the local language
so to say that like the church has
evolved over the last 20 years for
somebody with my background
it doesn't sound like an assumption but
i can understand
where you're saying it it does come
across to you like an assumption
no just to me is to say it's changed 20
years it could in your eyes and your
lens but to others it may be the same it
is today as it is 20 years ago 40 years
ago but
by the way everything you said it's a
level of skepticism i have myself
who sits there and looks at it i was
raised in a similar kind of an
environment
a christian family in iran where we got
a bombed 167 times in a day i'm
wondering if god really loves why are we
getting bombed 160
so i had a lot of my own challenges when
i went about it but
thank you for sharing that you know when
you say uh uh the
the basic uh needs being met i fully
agree
i think the part about it that it's by
choice not by force one of the
challenges i see happening too many
times with
men with us and you obviously you're
you're smart you're
you're a processor i'm very curious
about the way you think we may not agree
on
on a lot of things but i really enjoyed
this conversation i think the challenge
that happens with god
with people about 12 years ago i started
adding one thing to my affirmation list
and it was
stop trying to be god that job's already
taken you're not god let somebody else
do that you don't need to do that
i think too often man uh uh
and woman we try to
act like god to force our philosophies
upon
others and i think taxation is force i
don't think it's choice
and it drives a lot of the energy
innovators insane when it's not by
choice
the last thing you know you know they
asked jesus about that
in the bible so they said because there
was a debate
at that time and they they went to jesus
and they said jesus
help us solve this debate because you
have half the people saying
taxation is theft taxation is force
which i think is what you believe
i think by force it is yeah i do
and then on the other side they were
like
well you know it's really bad if we
don't pay taxes because look at what
happens and so
there was a group of people called the
zealots who were basically saying don't
pay taxes they were trying to get
everyone to not pay taxes i don't think
we don't pay tax just so you know i'm
not
yeah yeah i know i know it's a third i'm
a third i'm a third is where i'm at
just so you know so jesus said well
let me see that coin that you have
your money
who's on it you know what they said
caesar
i've heard this a million times yep and
so
the the idea that we have a financial
system is something that is
owned and protected by the common good
so we've gone to war for it i i don't i
don't defend us going to war for it in
in every circumstance obviously and
that's a whole other topic that i you
know
don't like war in general but you know
people have been drafted in our history
and then also if you look at you know
what happened
with native americans when we came here
if you look at you know the history of
slavery and how we got
it's really hard with all of that
context to think oh this money all
belongs to
me and i should be able to keep how much
i want because i know the history of how
how this became the way it is and i
think the responsibility that's there
is to do things like pay high taxes
so that that money can go back to making
some of those injustices trying to right
some of those wrongs and
i can't we can't look we can't go back
and change
what you live through as a kid right now
we can't but what we can do
is we can create hopefully a future
where fewer people will will be exposed
to that because that is
that's heartbreaking that you went
through that if we did an audit on your
money last year what percentage your
money was given to charity
oh i i i i think charities like
uh especially on the top end is kind of
a a pr
scam for billionaires no no no i'm not
talking about billy i'm talking about
you specifically i'm talking about like
you
what portion did you give to charity or
or how much money did you contribute
with time and money last year
2020 oh i'm i'm not i i'm not i i don't
want to sign up for an audit with you i
might i mean i might like do that
if i thought about it question the only
reason i'm asking that question is
because
yeah typically the people that impose
being the most
noble don't do a lot of it themselves
and and that is a form of judgment and
what i mean by judgment by that is
let the other person sit there and make
their own decisions when you're talking
about the money side
i fully agree i didn't sit there and see
all those events that happened where
uh great i grew up in a family where my
my dad was a 99 cent store cashier i
don't know what it is to be well i've
never lived in a house i've lived in an
apartment one bedroom
we don't have a clue what it is to have
money growing up as a kid so i
understand
what it is to be that person last part
of this interview again
this is probably going to go down as my
top 10 favorite interviews of all time
talking to you sincerely i want you to
know this sincerely
and the reason why one i applaud you
that you
agreed to do this interview kudos to
salute to you for willing to do this
because a lot of people say no
and uh secondly to be able to willing to
have that discourse i think the audience
one today
i think who won today is the audience
that's sitting there saying okay this
was great can we have more of this
and we're still laughing enjoying each
other's company and we're probably going
to get off and having a relationship
together
last part totally i'm going to give you
a name uh
tell me what comes to mind and if you
want to pass just say pass you don't
have to say anything but if i put a name
out there
tell me the first word that comes to
mind uh milton friedman
shareholder okay adam smith
uh misunderstood karl marx
um direction
okay uh elon musk
sad your favorite peter thiel
anger
bernie sanders um
consistency i agree he is for decades
aoc
um future
tag bill gates
i'll pass i i there's a word but i it's
going to take me like an hour to come up
with what it is
fair enough basils
um
the worst really okay biden
please did you say please like pleasing
everybody
okay and last but not least no no i
didn't need it that way i meant i'm like
saying please bro oh okay i got it okay
like please i gotta leave i got it
please and then last but not least
donald trump
um
who okay fair enough well
uh uh uh for the audience if you've
stayed with us the entire time which i
think many of you have because this was
very interesting
the book worth it is a book that our
friend here dan
price wrote how a million dollar pay cut
and a 70 million
minimum wage revealed a better way of
doing business his book came out last
year you can go order on amazon
we're going to put the links below and
to get a hold of him if you want to give
him any feedback
if you cut any part that he made any
assumptions or i did
let us know on twitter his handle we're
going to put up right next to him
and my handle is going to be right next
to me send us a message
and tell us what you took away from this
interview dan price thank you so much
for your time i really enjoyed it
thanks pat really nice to be with you
you got it buddy
so if you enjoyed today's interview i
want to hear your thoughts there's a lot
of different discourse debate
philosophy some of you guys that follow
him are probably here
trashing this video i want to hear it
all if you agree with me
disagree with me agree with them
disagree with them
comment below and if you enjoyed this
interview some tells me you're also
going to enjoy my interview
with professor leading socialist
professor according to forbes
magazine richard wolff another one but
we had a great time debating click over
to watch that
with that being said thanks for watching
everybody take care bye